[Music]
money doesn't grow on trees
but chopping them down has helped lots
of the world get richer
since the beginning of the 20th century
humans have been raiding these resources
almost as though they were Limitless
the problem is the world is now paying a
heavy environmental price
it certainly looks like a crisis after
the worst drought in 80 years so is
there a financial solution if we don't
change the movement of money we'll
continue to finance ourselves into
Extinction is paying for trees to be
protected and restored the answer and
how do you put a price on their worth
foreign
to understand the alarming story of
deforestation let's start with Costa
Rica in the 1980s
[Music]
Maria's family was typical of many
enticed by The Riches of Agriculture her
father cleared and converted their
Forest to pasture
foreign
markets with the driving force behind
deforestation
from 1940 to 1987 the proportion of land
in Costa Rica covered by forests
plummeted from 75 percent to 21 percent
Costa Rica's experience is far from
unique
the rest of the world jumped on the
bandwagon too
humans have been cutting trees for
thousands of years but there was a
massive acceleration in the last century
the U.N estimates around 10 million
hectares of forest are being lost each
year
that's around 27 football fields every
minute
fewer trees means less carbon dioxide
being absorbed from the atmosphere
and their destruction only adds more
emissions accelerating climate change
The Heart Of This Global crisis sits the
world's largest rainforest and the
so-called Trump of the tropics jair
bolsonaro
um
from 2019 to 2022 the rate of
deforestation in Brazil Rose by roughly
50 percent attracting critics around the
world
the problem is it's a bit Rich for
wealthy countries to demand that poorer
ones give up the economic benefits of
deforestation
the majority of deforestation in recent
years has really been driven by
agriculture expansion in developing
countries it can almost seem
hypocritical to criticize these
developing nations for following a
pathway that effectively made rich
countries wealthy in previous centuries
so what can be done
the simple answer is for rich countries
to incentivize poorer ones to protect
and restore their forests
one thing the wealthy world has tried is
stumping up cash for new tree planting
schemes but many of these haven't borne
fruit tree planting programs are
incredibly popular they can seem almost
childishly easy you plant a tree you
save the climate the reality of course
is nowhere near that simple in terms of
the climate it can be far more
beneficial to conserve the forest that's
there
so another way is to focus rewards for
developing countries on conserving
existing forests it works like this
using historic rates of deforestation a
country predicts how much Forest is
likely to lose in the future
any Forest that it manages to conserve
is judged against this Benchmark the
donor hands over a financial reward to
the developing country for the trees it
saved
paying a sum for each ton of carbon
dioxide that would have otherwise been
emitted
it's not just the developing country
that stands to gain the donors often
rich countries or companies can benefit
too in exchange for their money they can
claim what's called a carbon credit
which they can use to offset their
emissions elsewhere
Carmen credits are a way of allowing
companies countries people who can't
reduce their own emissions currently to
offset those emissions elsewhere they
are seen as an important part of
transitioning towards a net zero economy
I started out hugging orangutans but now
I find myself hugging asset managers and
bankers a bit more often Andrew Mitchell
is a zoologist turned financial advisor
he encourages investors to buy carbon
credits and believes they're an
important tool for Forest conservation
these credits are hugely valuable it's a
transition strategy whilst you're
reducing your carbon emissions you have
to buy offsets you should buy offsets
it sounds like a win-win but so far the
results are mixed Shady players have
gained the system and pulled dirty
tricks like duplicating credits or
claiming to conserve land never under
threat or moving the problem to the
forest next door
built into the Paris agreement is this
consensus that there should be a global
scheme for exchanging carbon credits
across borders in practice the rules and
standards that would govern such a
global market have been incredibly
difficult to establish and so right now
what we've got is a system which is
really unregulated and although
standards and the scale of carbon credit
schemes are improving there's still one
big sticking point the rewards for
conserving trees still lag behind those
for deforesting
we need carbon markets to grow they
won't really achieve their full
potential unless the price of offsetting
a ton of carbon is competitive with the
profits that can be generated from other
activities on that land ultimately
conservation has to become profitable
re-enter Costa Rica
once the poster child of deforestation
but now a global leader in conservation
and an example of how to make saving
nature pay
here landowners are paid by the
government to restore and conserve
forests
and this has helped to create new and
sustainable economic opportunities
[Music]
remember Maria whose father made a
living out of chopping down trees like
many in Costa Rica her family have since
branched out
and now do the very opposite
[Music]
Maria and her grandchildren we plant
forests so far 350 hectares worth
the government pays them and many other
families around 80 a year for each
hectare of forest that's restored or
kept intact
Graces
Ramos
[Music]
it might sound like a government subsidy
scheme but here's the key bit it's not
it's a system known as payments for
Environmental Services launched in the
late 90s is paid for by citizens who are
seen as benefiting from the services
provided by healthy forests like carbon
storage the protection of vital food
chains and clean water the money is not
coming from
from the national budget the money comes
from those who benefit
Carlos Manuel Rodriguez is Costa Rica's
former environment Minister and the
brains behind the scheme
which is paid for by a levy on consumers
water bills and attacks on their fuel
use
Costa Rica was the first developing
country that put a tax on on carbon to
generate a revenue for the payment of
Environmental Services everybody who
uses fuel in Costa Rica and pollutes the
environment contributing to climate
change must pay in the price of
purchases that fuel an extra amount that
goes to this foreign fund that pays
Farmers so far the scheme has invested
more than 500 million dollars in the
conservation of forests
and it's paid off in the space of a
generation Forest covering Costa Rica
jumped from 21 to more than 50 percent
with the restoration of trees have come
new opportunities for profitable and
sustainable Industries
blowing away the idea that conservation
and economic development are always at
loggerheads nature-based tourism has
become naturally important because of
our jobs in rural Costa Rica as opposed
to what we had in the past which was
this irrational
unsustainable agricultural production
there is no dichotomy between
preservation and economic development
since 1987 the peak of deforestation in
Costa Rica the country's GDP has risen
by an average of 4.2 percent a year
Costa Rica isn't a magic formula for
saving the world's forests
since it began prioritizing conservation
it's increased food imports an option
not available to all countries
but there is a lot Costa Rica can teach
others for one thing it's improved some
of its bad spending habits reversing
subsidies that incentivize the clearance
of land at all costs a lead more
countries should follow we should put
more money into the protection of nature
from governments but the reality is even
if we doubled all that money it wouldn't
come close to beating the subsidies that
directly cause harm to Nature each year
the world spends around 150 billion
dollars on protecting nature
but around 12 times that on subsidies
that harm it
some campaigners argue a more radical
fix is needed to save the volume of
forests necessary to avert environmental
catastrophe
they say what's required is a
fundamental shift away from society's
focus on profits and growth the problem
with GDP is that it measures everything
we build and nothing that we protect
it's all beginning to change now people
are waking up to the importance of
keeping nature going to keep our economy
going not everyone supports such a
drastic change to economic thinking but
most do agree that change is not
happening fast enough
with the eyes of many global leaders on
other challenges the world is facing
multiple crises in the midst of all this
there is a risk that nature conservation
and the climate crisis are demoted in
the pecking order but climate change the
global climate does not wait for
short-term crises to pass
foreign
bullet that will reverse climate change
the world needs to urgently reduce
industrial emissions
and prioritize policies to decarbonize
economies but unless trees are worth
more alive than dead deforestation and
its Devastation will continue
I'm Tom standage Deputy editor of The
Economist and editor of the world ahead
to read more of our future gazing
coverage click on the link thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe